oh you're live we're live hey YouTube
Welcome welcome welcome wait hang on I
got to figure out how to tweet this link
on Twitter oh no but if I close this no
I can't do it I need Alex
I need Alex uh
uh wait
yeah
what I mean yeah share
on Twitter
welcome welcome to our CES Booth Best
Buy is popping I know right I know this
is Best Buy but you can't buy anything
just like AVN is not the strip club this
is not Best Buy uh welcome everybody we
have an announcement planned in 10
minutes
um I'll take you around our booth okay
that's just uh going here
uh
if you really don't want to do the demo
I will but why do you want me to do it
I'll do it yeah I just we you know uh
underage yeah Welcome to our booth I
can't show you that side of the booth
because it has secrets
Secrets come in 10 minutes we got to get
more people in here I hope someone's
spamming the Discord with this link
um I don't know if I can share the
Discord I did share to Twitter though
and I promise I'd share it on Twitter so
I'm sure the discords will find it
uh the yeah will you say my time at
Twitter was wasted absolutely not it's
not about the destination it's about the
journey and there was some good food
when I first got there it was delicious
smoothies acai bowls
it's on Discord great uh 350 was way too
cheap that's so boring what you want us
to ship little [ __ ] dash cams we ship
high-end high quality consumer
electronics all right
they say they're here for a deep what
who is this YouTube
who is this
what's up any questions
I got you a d you better ask questions
any more contributors it's yes we just
met ifini here Sunny East here
the food is a good part yeah they're
talking about Twitter
uh tell us about CEs bro all right so
there's a lot of scams here yeah pretty
cool Booth a lot of people yeah we have
a pretty cool booth about a lake check
out the taco video
a bunch of uh devices
right uh
no no you think we are announcing a
partnership guys we're announcing things
that are going to directly impact your
life
Taco if it was a hit right
there is a Discord yeah discord.com
we did we took car and driver for a test
drive this morning it went well uh red
lights
spot on you guys know we do red lights
to stop signs now in experimental mode
um people don't believe this is real
people do not believe this can exist uh
it can the commentary is really an
amazing product
um there's no common four there's no
comma four I you know what I was
realistically I was talking we're trying
to buy chips from not Qualcomm and not
Nvidia because of those companies uh so
yeah we're at the comma four
realistically we say two years and it's
going to be more like three we're gonna
be on the commentary for a long time but
it's the common three right remember we
shipped the Eon the Eon gold and the
comma two which were all kind of part of
the same family we have a three device
family plan for the comma three and
they're gonna come slow uh this is still
uh still the comma three but the common
three you buy today is not the common
three you bought a year and a half ago
today's comment three has an all new
case
um today's comma 3 has just build
quality
uh the build quality of a comma 3 that
you buy today
the reliability of that device the
likelihood it's going to fail in the
next year is similar to a new iPhone
um common three Ultra maybe maybe not
today though not today
um not today all right so you guys got
to tell me when it's one o'clock so we
can do the announcements uh it's a quick
announcement I think you guys are going
to love it
um but yeah I mean you see the name of
the video the video is ready for growth
and we really are ready for growth it's
not one o'clock don't try me don't try
me
um
have we used our Trooper chip scanner
debugger uh it's not one o'clock
it's not one o'clock somewhere in the
world you guys don't know how time zones
work
T-minus eight minutes all right we got
seven minutes all right cool
um
not body related not body related it's
not a partnership
well how long should Red fan is
integrated into the common three that's
not the announcement today that'd be a
cool one though
um
but we announced a merge acquisition why
the hell do you want that do you not
like products you can buy do you want us
to get acquired by a scam company who
will stick all the tech in a corner you
think I would allow that
this stream is seven minutes behind yeah
funny
um no back camera you can't do a smack
come on you guys act like you want scams
you guys act like you want scams
um
are you on Booth every day yeah but if
you come here and be a fan you know how
I feel about fans like if I go up to Sky
Bree and I'm like hi Sky Bree I'm a big
fan I saw you on plug talk would I do
that no because it's lame don't be lame
you want to talk to me like a person I'm
here
uh
uh no scams please right right that's
what I'm talking about comma
a taxi no no taxi no Taxi
uh AI girlfriend uh no no later later
later
yes so we are ready for growth you can
see the three rocket ships and the title
of this video
um we are announcing a chip production
facility absolutely that's what it is
you figured it out
uh does common work in any country yeah
what you think we have a region lock
well you think we're the DVD people
you want to say hi to YouTube
hello
you're on my road no I'm not the common
robot
no
no
we got a blog post we got blog post
going live at one I'm very excited for
the announcement guys it's been pretty
wild it's been nice
um yeah we did a drive this morning up
uh
straight Vegas Road multiple red lights
it's good
[Music]
uh you know red lights are good but
they're not always perfect
um oh we got harnesses we got harnesses
do you have a harness
oh you need to bring a box
all right oh just on our website
nice looking harness right that's the
Toyota harness
can common three stop and go with
traffic lights yes
yes it can
we're hiring zero Biz Dev people here we
got the crowd around our booth
no no no no no you want to be on the
YouTube video
go to buy one go ahead that's right
don't say what other things are on that
sign though
all right all right how long we got to
one
four minutes
comments should automatically drive you
to the nearest charger
no no spoilers this comes out in four
minutes
did you guys watch White Lotus no
spoilers man every week you gotta wait
you got to be patient it's for semi's do
you have a Sammy here's our list of
supported cars here's our support of
cars and just when you thought that was
like whoa that's a lot of cars well
guess what they're all different on the
back
but you you can't even believe they're
different on the back but they are 200
Cars it's more than 200 bucks
I'm growing right like growing Daniel my
boy
uh
no why
yeah why
oh this is bigger
yeah large iPads are great
yeah they're different cars Bros you
think you think we're messing around we
did not partner with the CCP no no we
did not it did not happen
check it out Bros we got some we got
some consumer videos
open pilot should be more popular than
Chachi EBT yeah man
look it's a slow and steady grind but we
are going to win
[Music]
foreign
self-driving cars
Toyota security you got to vote whenever
you want to vote Greer you're welcome
this is your event congratulations
uh
introducing the comma question mark okay
we're gonna if the commentary we have
the price put you only 50 get a comment
rate it's like a loot box you know
or how about this well we'll make it 90
off but only a one percent chance you
get it what do you think loot box
loot boxes are illegal that's right
um
hello from Nebraska hey Brevin
free comment three-way you think I'm
Oprah
nah Alex thought I was Opera you want to
talk to YouTube
hey guys welcome to CBS
thanks for tuning in Shane you want to
talk to me
uh I'm a marketing intern I'm here doing
marketing as you can see
you want Shane Shane they want you
people are asking they wanted to even
though they didn't ask him any questions
do you have any questions
gotta push too long oh Shane's got to
push the blog no no Shane's got work to
do guys we can't distract him
all right is it one o'clock
that's 12 59 all right one minute guys
one minute one minute we got 255 people
in here what's the big announcement now
it's one
the food in early is good the food to
come is better trust me
all right all right it's time all right
wait you took away the one thing I was
going to show them
okay what is it being updated with
uh Alex delayed the announcement
Alex delayed it
back what do you guys think of Alex
delaying the announcement it's right
there oh it's right there okay it's back
okay guys in ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
six
one the price is now
14.99
14.99
it grows
Bros
Jesus you want this one
did you lower the price even more no I
mean our website bigger oh you made the
comment AI bigger
ah there we go guys 14.99 look at that
common.ai uh so I think the Shop's live
if you want to buy it right now for
14.99
um
the comma 3 is definitely a consumer
products this one's really good the new
ones are so reliable we talk about this
a bit in the blog post if you buy a
commentary today it has reliability on
par with an iPhone
um you know close the loop fix every bug
we do it yeah uh 32 gigs oh yes and it's
14.99 for the base model and we're not
scamming on the storage anymore 15.99
for 256 and 16.99 for the cross country
one terabyte the new price is look it's
an experiment guys if sales don't go up
price goes back up right but if sales go
up price days
uh yeah the site's still got a few
places the site they say this I still
got a few places where it says 1999
you can order it for 1500 right now
uh the blog's deploying we got a blog
post coming out uh we're really ready
we're ready for growth guys uh tell your
friends there's never been a better time
to buy
um you know I know people have said
about remember the comma 2 was at the
end of kind of a long product life cycle
right the eon eon gold and the common
two were all part of the same 821 uh IMX
390 family uh these
are
got at least two more years
um got at least two more years probably
three
uh oh yeah yeah they're working on it
look chains out to his laptop right now
uh we're fixing them uh we don't work
with anybody we don't work with abtera
you don't understand comma doesn't work
with people we work with cars right I
don't know if we support epterra it's
not a production car when it's a
production car we'll think about it
um
uh major Hardware changes no major
Hardware changes
uh same screen same old lead uh in the
comment three you're definitely more
tempted right
we did we did uh we did a survey and the
new prices within a region that should
sell a lot more
um you guys can see I published the data
on the blog
I'm a marketing intern I'm a marketing
intern and at Twitter I showed up and
demanded refactors and a comma I'm like
comma your biggest problem is that your
price is too damn high so you know the
price is too high we need to cut it and
we did uh we did and same quality
actually the quality is even better than
when it first came out because we have
refined the [ __ ] out of our
manufacturing process uh best card of
the common three Toyota Corolla can't go
wrong now they Sonata ev6 all great
choices
lower price better software better
Hardware buy now that's it that's it uh
14.99
um
open source the common three car mount I
think it's open source if it's not open
sources
uh Nick's not here so I would ask Nick
about that
uh OLED at 14.99 amazing deal right
no this is um look
we did by bringing our manufacturing our
manufacturing in-house and by increasing
the reliability of the device we uh did
a lot to make it
you know to lower our costs so we can
pass the savings on to you
uh if you had hardware issues with the
C2 you will not have them with the C3
um the original c3s were about five
times better the new c3s are about 10
times better
monitor
yes yes
um keep optimizing bomb we're working on
it we're working on it what's the runway
we're getting profitable this year
we are very likely to be profitable this
year and that makes our Runway of course
Infinity
um
see c3's 10x more reliable than all the
previous Target that's true uh no
trade-ins for common twos
uh
never raise again you never say never
right like we got a good deal on our
last round you know you never say never
raise uh that's just bad business if
you've got a good deal never raised from
VCS we didn't race for VCS we raced with
some cool people some of our investors
are here uh when did the new C3 Hardware
begin rolling out uh we moved to our new
office about six months ago
so the new uh production line is just a
lot cleaner a lot better and that's how
you get quality
in Europe I'm not sure uh orders placed
in the last 30 days no we're not doing
refunds come on guys come on
um
you know come on
you buy it at that price you get it at
that price you got to be fair here
uh lidar is a low interest rate
phenomenon that's true
uh newcomer dress shirts I don't know so
made in America hell yeah San Diego uh
is Toyota Corolla better with Taco Bell
that's pretty good uh we did all the ev6
the corolla's longitudinal is a little
bit better actually we we made some bug
fixes we're using the ev6 as our demo
car so we made some bug fixes for the
ev6
um have any large manufacturers in choir
they're not serious uh they aren't
serious we have no interest in working
with manufacturers uh it's it's not
it's it's structurally not going to work
uh we are going to build better cheaper
and well maybe not cheaper than this
14.99 is pretty low but um
people are happy we gave you what you
wanted we lowered the price that's right
who's the boss at comma well Alice is a
CLL and haroldia so those are the bosses
you're the president I'm the I'm the
president but I don't get it confused
I'm not a president like one of those
democratically elected presidents I'm a
president like one of those like like
you know dictatorships where the guy
tries to like give himself a fake title
for legitimacy that's the kind of
President I am
a marketing intern it's true
did Alex fire the prices go up
Department no I did I came back in and
I'm like guys guys we got to do
something about the price it's too high
I went outside and I was like oh my god
I've never spent two thousand dollars on
anything in my life so we lowered the
prices 14.99 now
uh interns make change that's right
that's right we had to do something we
had to do something about the price it
was insanely High we couldn't ask you to
pay two thousand dollars now it's 14.99
which is basically the same price as the
comma 2 was uh but there's been a little
bit of inflation and you can thank um
you know uh Biden for that yeah you
think Biden and Trump if you like the
inflation
um so it's really the common two price
the price is still showing 1999 on the
website
check it all check it all
it's right in the shot and honestly okay
it checks out it's 14.99 in the car
um
rip grip's good right
uh it's 14.99 for you hard fresher hard
refresher two minutes ago all right to
play two minutes ago but it feels good
but it's live everywhere right great
let's see all right what our options
look like oh wow the cross country 16.99
that's insane boys
oh man
oh guys
right now because we are low on
inventory we will make more but it could
be it could be a short wave actually if
you want a common three you should buy
it right now we don't have that many in
stock we're just doing it guys you know
what I learned something at Twitter and
the question is what would Elon do and
Elon would cut the price because it's
the right thing to do and that's why we
cut the price
you don't like my hardcore haircut
um yeah any other questions
200 extra for the harness well if you
bought a comma two you don't need a
harness
uh can you got it for Black Friday can
you return and by now no
um
the best car for common three Toyota
Corolla is a solid Choice Fiona Sonata
is very good uh the ev6 is probably the
best
uh 1700 with a free harness you can
consider it that
[Music]
um should have live stream this on
Twitter yeah we could have we could have
uh we're on YouTube We tweeted about it
I don't know if I trust Twitter's live
streaming yet uh we need the software
and servers guy to you know beef that up
a bit
um is the dev harness the same as the
comma serial oh no it's the same as the
comment too though
radarless is uh yeah the ev6 demo we're
doing for all the press and YouTubers
now is radarless
you gotta Elon it right
uh you gotta Elon it right what would
Elon do he'd lower the price so we're
lowering the price
over there
how fast is new model support pretty
fast
um will it work with a 2023 Corolla uh
we'd have to you have to ask them
um
I said I wouldn't lower the price well
guys I quit and I came back as a
marketing intern and then I lowered the
price right George hotz as president of
comma would never lower the price his
favorite people were the prices go up
department but when I came back as a
marketing intern and I did market
research by the way check the block
I did actual market research it's like I
hired McKinsey or KPMG that's how good
this market research was
so I did market research thank you for
buying
um I did market research and I found out
that we were charging the price was too
damn high so we we cut it we lowered it
um and look a lot of this is because we
brought all the manufacturing in-house
which lowers the costs
uh the intern might get fired to be
honest I might get fired if this price
cut doesn't go well
uh for people if this doesn't go well
for the company I'm probably going to be
fired and they're going to put the price
back up I mean you know I had to fight a
lot of political battles to get that
price lowered guys there's a lot of
internal there's a lot of resistance
against lowering the price but you know
I fought man I fought I did politics
that's a distributed system guys
um just bought another common three yeah
keep it going buy common threes let's go
let's go
uh no you're not gonna get a better
price than this uh yeah you're not
getting a better price than this
injection molded case is beautiful it's
really beautiful in fact in fact
the injection molded cases is the third
rev of it the third rev is good
is this the first time I've ever lowered
a price it might be honestly we were
charging too much the common three was
too expensive the common three is now
the same price as the comma 2 was but
there's been some inflation
um what do I just wait for a while to
allow the price again I don't think
that's happening the price may go back
up this may be temporary
um
no comma 3s light
[Music]
uh no
[Music]
but really not
um
they might go back up it might it might
it might happen will it work with your
Tesla no uh maybe
Georgetown isn't coding anymore he's
writing movie scripts doing marketing by
the way if you didn't check out my
Avatar 2 script on my blog it's fire I
wrote a much better Avatar too than
James Cameron and he should hire me to
consult them the next movie
um boom ordered yeah let's buy some
common threes guys you have a comma two
any advantage to getting the comma three
uh it drives better it works better it
looks better it's just better
like I have an iPhone 6 any advantage to
the new iPhone yeah your iPhone 6 kind
of sucks bro it's old
um finally got you to upgrade from the
gold yeah keep that old Hardware now
they're really good the new comment
threes are really good uh do I price
match no no price matching [ __ ] that's
the price you can buy one
um
comma phone when we're not making a
phone what's my marketing strategy well
I don't believe in that
uh how's Baltimore integration going
very good very good uh we have a multi
UV uh a lot of people are buying it for
the bald I think you'll have a great
time if you buy it for the vault
uh when it's gone before
three or four years
realistically I say we gotta look I have
some people here we got to talk about
chips for the comma four we're gonna get
a new chip but
it's it's a long time away but I'm not
just saying that I'm really not just
saying that you guys can believe me or
not but like you know the commentary is
still pretty new
um yeah the price went down a little
bit
um what chip does coming through use
Snapdragon 845
uh the red panda doesn't come with the
cables needed can you have two common
threes one in your front rear window
yeah but it won't do anything in your
rear window I just can't handle the
trolley problem we disengage and we let
you handle it ethical dilemma should not
be decided by computers
foreign
not really
um will there be another Comic-Con
Alex is like no I'm never doing that
again
um guys and I will Comic-Con make
avocados
Alex loves Comic-Con
uh show the zukes booth it's over there
can you buy it with PayPal Credit I
think so can I buy with paper cutter you
can yeah PayPal allows you to buy things
with credit you can
public release development 1.0 Comic-Con
confirmed hey guys mark your calendars
well we're doing we have a day right
yeah we have a date yeah yeah
comic-con's coming back are we turning
this into a full announcement of
everything no they asked I'm just I'm
just asking questions I don't like to
lie to the people ever you know that
another self-driving car awareness too
or no that's actually not happening that
will never happen I don't think it's all
right we'll remember zukes they're here
they're here they they have a nice they
have a really expensive sign I don't
know who paid for it but the zook sign
cost the entire cost of our entire
probably right yeah uh we don't know who
paid for the zoo sign because it doesn't
make any money
what do you mean Amazon paper they're
sugar daddy oh they're sugar daddy
Amazon pay for it that's a good point oh
is Tiny come over no way I'm a marketing
intern here and I'm gonna move on and be
an intern somewhere else I interned with
this good food
um does it work with right hand drive
cars absolutely yes coolest Tech besides
comma
do you want to go on a walk around is
there another consumer no no uh this is
only the announcement we can go on a
walk around ourselves a private walk
around the other maybe I'll maybe I'll
stream that on my twitch I haven't seen
it someone brought a Tesla in Corning
yeah Corning has a Tesla in their Booth
that's the other Tech I've seen here uh
how can you work a comma you can apply
Alex Smith jobs at comma.ai work at
comma.ai we're gonna have a hackathon oh
tell tell them about the hackathon I
don't know anything about hackathon I
don't work here anymore I'm a marketing
intern no one briefed me
um it's Harold hackathon he has a real
Vision oh that hackathon oh [ __ ] that's
how I got a lot of Secrets prepare
yourself prepare yourself Harold does
have a vision for hackathon beefing up
your githubs any progress in common body
we got we got look comma robotics
you think there's no future in
self-driving cars after five years we're
going to build an absolutely perfect
add-on [ __ ] system and then we're going
to Pivot to home robotics tell them that
this year
you can see our booth is very small we
have a 10 by 10 booth the bodies didn't
fit they were too fat they gained weight
they've been eating but next year next
time big Booth oh no we're not getting
we're not getting a big booth next year
robotics common robotics is getting a
tiny boot if you just won't have any
comment to these because everyone
already know about it
you don't don't make me go there guys
we love tests we love Tesla that's right
Comic Con this year too
Comic-Con is coming back
July 31st we booked it might we might as
well soft announce it yeah yeah I don't
know what stocks you should it's not a
launch conference
I never would have bought meta and lost
lots of money it's gonna be a party for
comma gonna come it's gonna be all
things comma
um
we don't have any more stuff do we you
think we're working on a new product
that's like
oh nah we just slowed the price of the
commentary that's right
you tell them about insourcing yeah
through the blog post no I don't know
how to get to it on my phone so it's a
lot of like links we don't do
collaborations we don't do Partnerships
I don't know what any of these words
mean guys if Boston Dynamics open
sources robots will play with them
you want to collaborate it's on GitHub
they're not shirts they're um we got
jumpsuits we got we got a jumpsuit and I
got a jacket
comma swag I can't hear her no I can't
hear the camera
I don't know what Foss dam is
uh when's comic an IPO never you think I
want to sell myself to bankers
wait we are selling a consumer product
the comma 3 is a consumer product guys
we call it a dev kit if that bothers you
too much it's not for you but it's a
consumer product and it's a good one
uh open pilot V1 oh it's literally a
deaf kid it says the worm Dev kid oh no
man that's the thing if your mind can't
think outside the box it's not for you
um
lose a couple hundred dollars you bought
a good product at a good price and now
there's a better price you know that's
just what happens
at least you didn't buy metastock and
lose 75 000 last year like you know and
don't even get me started on my gptc
like you know wish I could return that
[ __ ]
oh I'm probably uses Tony grad right
um new features win wait did you not try
experimental mode is that not everything
you want red lights stop signs turns nav
on open pilot uh is it a branch you can
try the taco Branch if you want to even
have an open pilot it's going to come to
release probably
three months George you got to become an
official twitch streamer stream to the
twitchies yeah no I love the return rate
what is it ten percent yeah it's for
hovering around 10 I think yeah
it's gonna be lower with the new crazy
low price no it's actually too low we
need to raise our turn right I think it
was sub 10 it was like I'm telling you
just buy it even if you're gonna return
it
Axel Nick's still alive we don't talk
about axle next anymore it's done it's
done and we didn't pay him any money and
that's what matters so
uh with the comma 3 work in a boat
I mean what do you want it to do
you want to drive the boat I don't know
if it's gonna drive the boat
does boat
uh can you show the comment three you
want to show them come today yeah of
course here's a comments right yeah
it comes with a beautiful
organic LED screen you know that's what
the oh no that stands for it comes with
a those nice dark 80 degree fisheye
camera
beautiful IR LEDs which light up your
face at night you see what our driver
monitoring is up here
then on the back here
we have the common three has two eyes it
has two ears it has a mouth for speaking
it has a mouth for breathing and it has
two USBs this one is a real USB this one
is an obdc which connects to your car
screws this is a wide GoPro Mount Tia
they want to know why newer comma threes
are better than older comma 3s they've
just been more rigorously tested also
just look at this case right do you
remember the case of the older common 3
how it had like little bumpies in it we
got good at injection molding just
this is absolutely beautiful plastic
this plastic is rated up to like a
hundred and
I think it's 160 Celsius it's something
crazy Igor would know
[Music]
um
uh the new plastic is rated to some
crazy high temperature uh this whole
thing is like you can bake these things
at 105c and they're fine and you you can
put them up to 125 and the only thing
that will happen is the screen will go
off color and you've never been at 105c
that's boiling water nice
these things deal with heat like you can
leave them on your windshield
um yeah they're good
have more questions
do you 3D print anymore or just moved
over to injection molding it's still 3D
print for a bunch of our things but uh
the common threes are injection molded
how many commentaries did we sell in
total five thousand the one about the
failure rates failure rates yeah yeah so
the failure rate at like pretty much
launch of the comma 3 was 5x lower than
the comma 2. the new comma threes it's
about 10x lower than the common two
um which puts it but the commentary was
about 25 uh the new failure rate's like
2.5 uh which is on par with a modern
iPhone
did we find a new SOC vendor no we're
using Psalms and then yeah we got to
move away from all coming to video These
companies aren't the future
um
[Music]
do you guys do wholesale for car dealers
so we'll give is it 15 off for 10. oh we
got to make that ten it's just too long
now
we gotta make it tap oh get in yeah
don't tell him to get in we gotta we
gotta make a ten it's ten percent off
it's 10 off you buy chattermore
uh it's self parking possible self Park
is bad the only features you actually
want are places where the system can
drive better than you and that's Highway
stop and go and in experimental mode
that's uh you know a bunch of sheets
with red lights
I did not talk to Elon about common
threes to Twitter
mqb badge cars do they work I don't know
you have to ask a deep about that how
about summon mode oh come on they're
gimmicks you don't want that
are there any car dealers that are
installing these I think there might be
yeah you can ask I don't know
um Obama Works in right hand drive
countries too yeah in fact there used to
be a toggle but we removed the toggle
and switched it all to Auto detect
because people didn't know about the
toggle uh yeah but we have an input to
the model but we put in whether it's
left hand drive or right-hand drive and
it works a little common three integrate
learning on device we're working on it
um there is already a good bit of
learning on device uh I think we call it
params d
uh want to enter in a bank no uh when
can you expect Edie long for FCA
whenever you make it work no we'll get
there order it all thank you thank you
thank you 1tb red panda you're gonna
love it
um the stop and go at traffic lights is
live today yes it is already in release
there's a toggle from chill mode to
experimental mode
um so chill mode is a traditional ACC
system experimental mode is end-to-end
longitudinal uh and it will stop at red
light the stop signs today the demo that
we're doing for the Press is on release
pretty much there's a few fixes to the
evcx which we'll get out in the next
release but they're very minor fixes uh
red lights are already live the model is
already live
what oh hold the phone oh okay
all right uh speed bump detection yeah
experimental model slow down for Speed
bumps
uh still planning on making our own
chips eventually
was most egregious performance improving
bug I wasn't here for it I'm a marketing
intern guys uh is stock FCA disabled
when the C3 is installed I don't know
um you ordered the basic unit if you're
doing a new model Port do I need
anything other than a harness no harness
is fine fix the slower speeds on ede
um
worse than experimental mode you got it
you gotta talk that you wanna Harold can
answer these questions but he's not here
I don't know where did Harold go I think
he got food I think you got food
why don't I hire an agency oh I'm bored
would I like to see a web only OS
sure Jack sure
um my next job I don't know
yeah
[Music]
no we're not
Alex we're just not gonna do it
that's it this is our last thing yes
guys
um
how can you contribute to the growth by
comma threes tell your friends
I think it's time I think I think we hit
a price point now where we're going to
start to seize a bit of virality
uh you want chain or Harold to talk
uh uh I can get I don't know I don't
know if I want to talk I don't know how
it is Harold's getting food
um
Shane they want to hear you talk
yo YouTube what's up I have a fork I
don't update I'm sorry
any questions
oh oh we have Mike D uh Cameron and I
worked on that so uh you should adjust
the volume for the sounds and adding
record adding recording soon so that
should be nice
uh let's see
smart land switch I'll have somebody
open a PR in my fort get a good software
any other questions
support getting better I mean you had
support for cars every every week every
day so it's autotune just the KF tune
what's Autumn what are we showing
auto-tune is good that did a nice job on
that so check it out
how old
I did I had no programming experience
how old so the question was how old was
I when I contributed open pilot I had no
experience pretty much like in this kind
of environment and I just looked at the
source code and saw what I wanted to
change
I just started learning how to build
base so yeah it could be you guys you
just gotta work hard
I'm nobody's boss guys I'm a marketing
intern
do I have the power to fly with the
internet I don't know
let's go to the board for that
um got anything else but they were
complaining about some experimental mode
things maybe Harold would know they want
to know they were saying Wyatt like
doesn't slow down for Hills or something
oh it kind of just got cooked before the
release next update should be pretty
good
jobs y'all were hiring we're hiring guys
we're hiring
oh we want to make a b work on all the
cars
car interface engineering car team
fix all the bugs fix all the bugs a lot
of bugs
oh he's research hiring I don't know
I don't know what research is research
is off getting food we're always hiring
good people we're always hiring good
people that's right if you have evidence
of exceptional ability that's kind of
always the policy that's always
desperate for people no research needs
yes we're fully on site no remote jobs
that's not a job you can pretend to work
somewhere else
we can work remotely for Comma just make
a pull request on our GitHub
will there ever be eat no we don't have
any full remote and no there will not be
East Coast offices we have one office in
San Diego it's beautiful
uh calibration challenge
yeah bro West Coast for Life bro what do
you want
security rolls what's this what's a
security role I got I got I can hook you
up with the one uh we have in front yeah
yeah you want to work on infra
absolutely
um
criminal trying to copy com AI there's
some clones you can buy not of comma
threes of comma twos they're kind of
mediocre
but they're cheap so it's up to you
no we can't drop the price of connect we
lose money on connect what price do you
want connect to be
what causes 26 each to really get 24
from you we lose money I can't lower the
price I gotta raise it
a deep a deep suggested it should be 44
yesterday
orders
like I could do anything
well I can't tweet because I'm on
YouTube
the food's good
the blog is live go to blog.com read the
blog post
uh question from the audience
no I'm not going
uh
uh maybe you know everything's always
possible
um
will the small storage competition
perform better in the bigger storage
option yeah it's the same driving it's
just about how much storage you got yeah
yeah um can I make navigation free no
navigation is part of prime you have to
buy it it costs us money I have to pay
for the map box API you don't understand
like you think these things are free for
me I have to pay for them
and then I gotta pay for the Azure for
you guys it's already too cheap it's too
cheap to be honest we just lowered the
price of the comma three you know
don't make me regret it by the way if
you guys all don't buy comment threes
I'm gonna regret it and then I'm gonna
get fired and then they're gonna put the
price back up
oh I'm missing out on great job Talent
by alienating remote work if you want to
work remotely you really don't take your
job seriously
um
yo yo welcome
do you want to say you want to say hi to
the live streams
[Laughter]
look who we got in our booth it's Jim
Keller good to see you
we just we just cut the price yay 19
14.99 yay
um
and chip with Jim we're not at the scale
yet we've talked about it we've talked
about it uh
maybe
um
maybe in uh no no we don't know security
is everyone's job uh
when will the AE Model come back the a
model's on the taco Branch you can use
it
wait Harold's here do you want to
complain about experimental mode to him
called into the manager's office
Jim has a Tesla what's wrong with
experimental mode
[Music]
it seems like everyone's happy with it
wait can you show a video of stop and go
traffic he's in common three yeah you
can do that we've
drives too slow oh the height was a big
thing that was discussed uh Anatolia is
complaining that he's got a palisade
yeah yeah we're working on that yeah
we're working on that we're building the
data set with tall cars hopefully in a
couple weeks there's a mall already with
that yeah
uh drove into a lake
what someone said bro if you drove into
a lake the amount of little attention
you were paying
I did see that episode of The Office
though
um what's a sequel developer no we don't
we're not hiring any prompt Engineers
either that's not a real job
what do you mean
to write what
wrote this video
[Music]
how [ __ ] is the code it might be
what did you tell them did you give it
the prompt that I have to write yeah yes
you were you were you were you were a
multi-usamo winner who has spent many
hours grinding at least code
yeah if you really want a knee look the
knee is scary no the knee is
legitimately scary you don't want a knee
it's scary
yourself
it shouldn't cross it really should not
Cross Lane lines if it's Crossing Lane
lines post the video it really shouldn't
happen
uh open pilot and snow you shouldn't be
using it in snow really like if it's
heavy snow if it's like snow on the side
of the road it should be fine Apple Care
like warranty extension yeah
is it is it comicare time
it's so reliable you know people like
the parts store I like the parts store
can we tell them the daily rate number
yeah you told them it's like two percent
guys it's incredible they don't break
they don't break they're not coming twos
um
yeah but no I mean then we absolutely
should offer comic care and just get
free money from worry words
right
we gotta deal with it you guys
I don't know
it's still easier than dealing with
apartment hackers
experimental and two-lane freeway will
drive about 10 miles an hour slower in
the right lane than the left
that makes sense but is that not what
humans would do yeah
what
that's somewhat by Design I guess why
did comma twos break because it was a
cheap Chinese cell phone and a 3D
printed case
that was 25 as well I was trying really
hard to make sure they did it oh yeah no
like we tried too like it's not like
we're like oh we want them to break I
swear to you
yeah we down clocked them it cost me
half a million dollars because those
things broke like out of pocket I'm out
half a million dollars all right so you
know
I never want to hear that offensive [ __ ]
that I wanted him to break I really
didn't but on the common three of you
tried really hard
um we're gonna focus on experimental
mode now that the Taco Bell video is
done so if you're not happy with how
it's driving it's uncomfortable post it
and it's slowly going to get better the
high cars is the first thing that we
know how to fix that that's on the on
the schedule oh yeah we got to fix our
high cars
yeah well we're including them in the
data set oh all right that's good yeah
do you think if you had better marketing
brand Direction design look we're
interested in design I'm a marketing
intern as a meme we don't actually
believe in marketing guys
we want to make nice stuff nice is good
design is engineering Elon actually said
exactly those words design is
engineering
yeah yeah seasons tweetings
you need to get eyes on the product no
no no we need to make a product that's
at a good price point that provides
value such that it'll go viral and
that's all you need
this is marketing no this is [ __ ]
talking
there's no visual language I think
there's a visual language
um
is there a fully self-driving plan what
do you mean by fully self-driving
for comma by an aptera nah
I don't know
I'm not I'm not that interested
uh I mean it depends like things that I
like and this is just me like I like
cars with good uh nice and quiet
Interiors good ride quality I used to
ride a motorcycle younger Me Maybe
younger me would like to have Tara
um comma nfts you guys think we're gonna
start skimming you just saw an exit cam
we're gonna exit cam
any new lawn control breakthroughs come
in Subaru or other yeah I mean I think
yeah but it's not nothing's a
breakthrough but wait do we have
experimental model supers
there's a PR part okay
I mean yeah
is it is it responsive
um
I think we can yeah I think the Subarus
I mean now that the promise Subarus they
don't have Radars but now that we can do
experimental mode on cars without Radars
I think we're going to see a lot better
stuff want to see the video stop and go
at lights
yeah we're coming out this has been the
demo drive for everyone
oh yeah that's a good point if you want
to see it from the perspective of the
device we can make one public also just
watch the taco video like the taco video
is experimental mode with like a hundred
line change that you can read it's all
open source so that guy on Twitter who
was like you guys didn't open source it
yeah we did it's in a branch bro
uh well Taco Branch navigate work on
cars other than ev6 I think so yeah we
didn't have on Op with the curl this was
yesterday morning I was doing it uh
it'll work it won't do the blinkers the
blinkers are ev6 exclusive
uh all canopyhound.com
would I rate our support our support is
very good if you depends what you want
right if you're looking for somebody to
hold your hand through the product our
support is not good if you're looking
for like the hardware broke and I need a
replacement our support is very good
um so yeah again if you're if you want
like emotional support no emotional
support if you want actual like dude
like my device won't turn on anymore and
I treated it really well we will have a
new device out to you really fast
um
if car is not moving as distraction if
car's not moving it won't progress past
the green alert uh the new DM is
the new DM is better the new DM you
should not be using your phone while
you're driving
uh so the new GM is more strict in
certain ways and less strict in other
ways right but false positives are
always bad
DM but again DM is not meant to always
catch you DM is meant to remind you that
you need to pay attention at all times
any plans for Mercedes no they're Flex
rate cars
you support your support thank you thank
you in some ways our support is very
good depending on what you're looking
for when is Taco Ranch going to hit the
Vault I mean you can just go in the
branch switcher and click taco
uh add auxiliary cameras you don't need
that you think you need that you don't
uh can mads be in alternative mode only
on Forks
uh does Tesla gdm now too apparently the
new model my friends bought a new model
3 and apparently they don't have IR
cameras
uh common did not have driver modding
before every car company super Crews had
it before us
uh no you will not be getting a refund
come on guys come on is that really you
want you want your 500 from me no
no you will not don't send in an email
being like well I bought it and then the
price went down oh come on
um how many active users does openpilot
have like 5 000 dailies
but we're ready for growth we want to
get that up to 10 000 by the end of the
year what do I drive uh Sonata
uh uh thank you thank you
um
if you make geohi nfts I will sue you
are we hiring for mobile front-end Dev
[Music]
if you have like one specific skill you
probably won't get hired here but if
that's what you kind of want to focus on
yeah there's a lot of stuff to improve
connect
um your average cost will go down
exactly if you bought one buy another
one your average cost will go down love
that
um
zero nine two you know like a month
is Jonah and one out
he's doing on one's out I don't want
your royalties no nfts of me
um what's up with the lawsuit loss it's
over lawsuit's over no money plus it was
dropped I don't really want to talk
about it anymore not because I can't
just because like you leave me alone
I'll leave you alone I'm a nice guy you
[ __ ] with me I'll [ __ ] with you like
that's just how it works
uh
yeah we want to get we'll get to 10K a
day this year we're at about 5k dailies
I want to get to 10K
I think we're going to stream for six
more minutes and then I gotta go home
and do a demo
uh high-rise radar and vision we don't
need any high-res radar give us an
update on common body common robotics
has some good stuff planned this year
um but we've been focused on the patent
troll is over
uh it's over I don't really want to talk
about it
it didn't cost us anything I promise you
I didn't give him a dollar
um
I did not give him a dollar
give him a dollar you think I'd talk all
that [ __ ] and then be like oh here take
my money no way
but like I said look you don't mess with
me I don't mess with you you mess with
me I mess with you that's just how it
works
um Sonata does it stop at the red light
yeah uh you can enable experimental
model Sonata right yeah
on a non-release branch yeah I'm not
really French for Sonata am I wearing
Sony on purpose no they're just the
sponsors of CES man
um is the settlement with a 10 million
races right now uh we bought a whole
production line in-house check out the
blog post go to blog.com.ai city streets
work in experimental mode
um become a body is going to be common
body will explode in popularity in three
or four years once it can cook and clean
for you
uh no I'm gonna turn in the marketing
department but we don't do marketing so
I don't really do anything
um well the navman limp would be in the
future versions you can see in the taco
Branch already we're putting in like a
it's a feature vector
uh from the uh from the from the
navigation UI
uh I don't know which car is better
they're both probably pretty good
uh if your car's running master will be
included in model training yes
um
I don't know about the Pacifica
doing uh
uh no we're done with the patent show
guys that's in the past that's in the
past
if you don't mess with me I don't mess
with you you mess with me I'm messing
with you all right
um
all right we're wrapping it up great any
last words you want to say to them
because we got we gotta get home
I'm sorry gotta get home where yeah guys
we have a big Tom's coming no I don't
want to say all right all right we got
we got we got YouTubers future plans
there's always future plans for Connect
hypothetically
um do I have anything else for them no
Jim and I were just chatting about how
many scams there are out there and I
just want to push the message that work
on something that's meaningful create
real value in the world Life's Too Short
collecting business cards and shaking
hands is not a job okay try it okay
that's right neither is remote work
remote work is okay for call centers
assistance
um I think there's a go and this isn't
actually true like look if you are truly
incredible of course we're making
Snapchats but most people who are like
could I work remotely no
remote against your will yeah I don't
like remote work I went and lived you
know how much I hate San Francisco and I
went and lived there for Twitter I think
you also need to tell people something
important about how Karma Works your
company is a design like how we
communicate and we're just not well
suited for remote work
um the way we work we don't have a jira
we don't Alex Alex is a lot nicer than
me we don't have a monday.com you know
we don't have anything it's monday.com
product management there's a website
called monday.com it's Marissa Mayer's
thing you know it's a product management
software they don't want to use it if I
had to go to monday.com that reminds me
of someone's got a case of the Mondays
if I worked at a job and I had to go to
monday.com
so anyway the point is
we are hiring
um Romo work is not bad
you know we do have a secret robe Works
remotely
if you worked at the company for two
years in person and then you want to
talk about remote fine we'll think about
it yeah
I work remote and I use I'll use the
teams yeah we don't have teams we don't
have anything if you've worked at comma
for years and then you want to go remote
because of some lifestyle things can
Harold Harold do people want to ask you
a few questions yeah do they want to
know all right I have a Herald here
shoot
I just saw it says old man
that's you the old man yeah come on
Toyota Corolla navigation open pilot
yeah okay well I want that too
what do you mean stop signs work have
you tried it
how far are we from training
specifically on disengagement override
oh that's a good question I don't know
we're still pretty far away from that we
keep talking about it
when is pedestrian detecting uh
uh I mean it detects pedestrians
sometimes
more videos about training it's fun to
see uh I mean did you see the uh
development speed blog post I gave some
insight into how our training stack
Works maybe we'll do some more technical
blog posts like that if people like it
Lexus Toyota nap I mean we're working on
nav it somewhat works there's just a few
things quirks to work out you gotta make
sure the map looks good to the model and
the model's never confused and then if
you're being rerouted that it you know
detects that and says like oh rerouting
Gotta Wait with an Avenue pilot but I
mean there are branches and they they do
kind of work I think it's pretty close
to shipping and experimental mode I said
like three months oh yeah that's
hopefully before then but that sounds
conservative you know I'm saying six
months stop sign struggling four lane
roads yeah because it's kind of like not
right next to you stop signs is hard if
the stop sign is not next to you but
it'll get better
messages are coming in comma three can
run comma three can definitely run Doom
[Laughter]
basically the Taco Bell Drive but then
like shipped and reliable 10 hours
between the sticks on 1.0
uh why is VW not supported more wait
it's super awesome it's supported isn't
it yeah
yeah new DM models performance versus
older models I don't know is that a
question
wait when is it fair mode cone coming to
Pacifica is it not on every car
sure is it on the
Branch
improvements are increasing the model
size no
use existing cat Ada's cameras never
work in European driving laws yes oh I
heard about the new European Fork oh
yeah
you put you'll use classifier free
guidance style training I don't know
what that means more technical blockbust
okay
I like technical blog posts
drastic stuff
I don't know if that's what it is I mean
we've tried some of that stuff it's
interesting maybe we'll work more in the
future
so we are using an autoencoder to talk
about that really makes it hard yeah
that's true yeah we really want to ship
that but requires some simulation
improvements
after Taco is launched what's next
feature-wise nothing
no that's actually it for teachers what
else do you want besides typing in a
destination in your car driving there
without a disengagement yeah
yeah the railroad tracks I've seen to be
confused to George hot's voice
directions well we are going to ship we
are going to ship uh you can your
destination should be enterable by voice
where you're going for now yeah
oh my Belgium exists by the way it's
just rubber yeah we pay for an office so
yeah
a robot doesn't work remote
do you all have brown eyes
first of all George has green eyes okay
nice
robo's actually three people
Lane change initialization I think in
the future we'll just have to train the
model to look at the scene and the map
and determine whether a lane change is
necessary and then propose one
I think that's what's up
um more blog more okay we can do more of
everything guys
what do you want what do you want less
of yeah yeah that's a good question
what are you using the auto encoder for
so the auto encoder is to ensure that
the embedding space we use to train the
models in the simulator contains uh most
information that would be relevant for
driving so like stop signs and stop
lights we want to be sure that's in the
embedding space and the auto encoder
basically enforces everything to be in
the embedding space can a human drive
from a reconstruction of the embedding
space
not yet but soon probably
Sentry mode I don't know we can't do
Sentry mode videos and blog posts
entry mode videos
we need to stream the videos take
snapshot is a terrible feature yeah it
needs to instantly come up with a video
not maybe send you a picture 12 seconds
later I mean we do have a connect
engineer now
what's wrong with you along send
feedback we'll fix it we're hiring if
you want to come work here and build
Sentry mode why are the side view
cameras no
specific Road placement no
you're not on the
uh oh we missed a lot and it flip off
that drive yeah that's how I went back
before
what cream should you use for dry skin
just lotion probably no no no fig one
best skincare oh okay no it's
life-changing actually check it out
figuon.com you get a putty scraper just
scrape the dry skin off here no I was
blowing my nose and it saved my device
learning is very far away we have one
devices where's okay sure I owned a on
device deep learning is very far away
we've got shallots
David
oh easier in construction it's getting
better during constructions especially
the auto encoder stuff will help
can you upload Drive footage to YouTube
easily
what are the clips explored us
my buddy jumped how did it even work oh
the knee oh I guess you gotta put a lot
of weight up top Denise very scary the
knee is scary
experimental mode to Hondas I think
there's also a branch for that
curious about all these cars
let's get a t-system Toyota we're gonna
Evac swimming
so cattle manufacturers look they
haven't locked us out don't worry
what time is it I don't know it's time
to go
two oh yeah
thank you for watching our video see you
guys
uh thank you for watching the video
this is an experiment
the new price is 14.99 uh tell your
friends uh we need sales uh if we don't
get sales the price goes back up but if
we get sales the price stays low for you
all right thank you all for watching
live from CES 2023 it's comma AIS booth